-You can see my first guest
every weekday on "The View."
Her 2020 holiday collection
is available.
Now, look at this.
Look at this scarf.
Can you see that?
It moves. It has things.
Nordstrom.com.
You can also see her
in Stephen King's "The Stand,"
which premieres December 17th
exclusively on CBS All Access.
Look at this. Here she is,
Whoopi Goldberg!
Whoopi!
-Whoo! Yay!
-You are the best.
I love you, buddy.
Always something fun.
Always festive.
You are the best. Why should
this year be any different?
-Well, you know,
I thought about that.
I thought to myself,
"What do I do?"
And I knew I couldn't
do a sweater,
'cause who was going out?
Nobody.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
Nobody's going out.
They're not partying
in sweaters.
-Nope.
-No.
So let's do scarfs and masks.
-Scarves and -- And it's so warm
and it's good and --
-Yeah.
-We need comedians at this time
in our life.
-Yes. We are very important
to everything, I think.
-I agree.
And another tradition
that you --
See, even through Zoom,
you come through.
-It breaks my heart.
I couldn't bring you --
'Cause you know I always
like to bring you sweets.
And all I could do
was give you one cupcake.
-But look at it.
-One cupcake.
-Look at that.
Look at that, though.
You did still deliver,
and, honestly, Whoopi,
you have to see.
Dave, could we have a two shot
so Whoopi could see
where I'm at, the wide shot?
This is me here.
There's nobody here.
-Ah.
-Hi, buddy.
There's no Roots.
There's nobody.
But we're gonna get there.
But right now,
it's just me and my cupcake.
-Well, that's not bad.
-And I'm gonna take a bite
for good luck right now,
because if this is from Whoopi,
it's always good luck
and good vibes.
Mmm!
-It's incredibly sweet,
isn't it?
I can see your teeth
are rolling up.
[ Laughing, stammering ]
Yeah. Yeah.
That's what happens when
I give it to my granddaughter,
my great-granddaughter.
She's like, "Ooh, sugar!"
-Yeah. That's like a Red Bull
right there.
-It's absolutely true.
-That is delicious. Magnolia.
-Yes.
-But I like your background,
what you have back there.
Are you into the Baby Yoda,
it looks like?
-I am. I love --
You know, I love him.
-I do, too.
-Because he's looking --
He wants to go home.
But the thing
that I love, like, a lot
is that I have a relationship.
Watch. Oh.
[ Toy coos ]
-Are you joking?
-You rub his head like this.
-Oh, no!
[ Toy coos ]
Oh, my gosh.
He is --
[ Toy whooshing ]
Are you joking me?
I love it!
-Is that the greatest?
-How great is that show,
by the way?
Jon Favreau just crushing it.
-You know, he does an
extraordinary job,
and it's just great.
And you want to be part of it,
and you want to watch.
And, you know, it's fun,
and, you know, you need it.
And you need a Baby Yoda
in your life.
-You know what I saw?
There's a documentary
on The Comedy Store
that I was flipping
through the channels,
and you were on it, and
I could not stop watching it.
I watched the whole --
-And Mike Binder did it.
-Mike Binder, and I was like --
At first, I go,
"Who is he? I know him.
But I forget
where I know him from.
His voice is familiar."
Then I go, "Oh, Mike Binder.
I totally know Mike Binder."
He directed "Indian Summer,"
which is one of
my favorite movies.
But talk to me
about The Comedy Store.
What do you remember about it?
Because it's a comedy club
in Los Angeles,
and there's three rooms, is it?
Or two on the floor?
-There was two...
-And then, one upstairs.
-...and then, one upstairs
which was The Belly Room.
-That's The Belly Room.
-Yeah, yeah.
And I got really lucky.
Only female comics --
That's where Mitzi
put all the females.
And then she -- When my show
really sort of took off,
she just gave me The Belly Room
to perform in
for as long as I wanted.
And that's what I did
and had the greatest time.
And, you know,
all the great comics,
like, all the great comics.
-Like Rodney.
-Rodney Dangerfield.
And watching Richard Pryor do
what he did from the wheelchair.
He was in the wheelchair
and still slaying people.
He would say stuff, and you
think, "You are saying this,
and your life has shifted,
and here you are,
and you are still,
you know, bar none,
one of the greats."
And, also, Robin
I saw there quite a bit.
And it's a wonderful --
It's a wonderful memory,
'cause you just --
You don't think about it
while you're doing it.
-While you're doing it.
-You only realize how amazing
it was when you get past it
and you're doing your own thing.
And they were all like,
"What do you do?"
I was like, "Well,
I kind of tell stories."
And they were like, "Really?"
I was like, "Yeah."
They said, "Okay,
let's go and see."
So, you know,
'cause people would say,
"Well, you're not a stand-up."
And I was like, "No, I'm not,
'cause I can't tell jokes."
I can mess up a joke
better than anybody.
You know, I just --
I'm not good at them.
But I'm a good storyteller.
-But is that where Mike Nichols
came to see you?
-No, Mike came to see me
downtown in Manhattan.
It was great,
'cause he was taking --
He was doing all three plays
at the same time,
"Hurleyburley," "Death of a
Salesman," and "The Real Thing."
-Whoa.
-So he decided --
They would take each other
to different shows,
and that was the show
that he got taken to.
And it was quite amazing
to see him,
because he would say, you know,
"Ms. Goldberg, how are you?"
And I'd be, "I'm fine.
I'm fine."
[ Both laugh ]
And my mother was like,
"That's Mike Nichols."
-Yeah. Gosh.
-They would point and look
and, you know.
-Genius.
-It's still to me as ridiculous
and fabulous as it was day one.
The whole ride is ridiculous
and fabulous to me.
-Yeah, I agree.
And you're acting again,
which is great.
You're in Stephen King's
"The Stand."
I want to talk to you
about this.
I know that you would be
totally into it,
and you're like, "Oh, this is
perfect. I want to be in this."
So let's talk about Stephen King
when we come back, alright?
More with Whoopi Goldberg
when we come back, everybody.
-[ Rapping indistinctly ]
♪ Yeah, on top
of the boss meter ♪